siete pronti per altre cagate di
amsterdam mamma belle forti perché
quelle altra volta erano leggere in
confronto bene let's go che bello
romantico sasha col verde dietro molti
comunque io ho iniziato registrare per
un motivo preciso ecco ecco ecco quanto
è mica un fenomeno però vado non pensavo
così atleta che ha troppa chi sa mai
allora siamo al dove fanno gli eventi
grossi che c'è anche il cartellone del
film grosso fanno gli eventi dei dj
quelli quelli più grossi questa cosa il
primo che me la passo minecraft vince un
dito nel culo
manca mai vinto un dito nel culo fa
freddo porco lui stacco tipo eschimese
mentre a maniche corte come perché
prendi la droga papa la droga pappa
reale e papà di droga papa book to good
man mano scappano perché cosa mi
intelligenti loro camminano
poi appena vede che fai comunque se ci
facciamo la foto con questo sfondo di
chi minchia la [ __ ]
cariati arriva proprio sotto casa nostra
vieni qua se sei gesù cristo funziona
nel backstage
bene bene sempre stiva
lo stadio della ion
chi strafatto di pappa reale come se non
ci fosse un domani
[Applauso]
ma che cazzo ma cos'è
[Musica]
si no
volevamo andare a mangiare italiano rega
ma guardate non ci avevo dubbi con
un'anima beaumont e anche un dubbio ci
avevo maria rap ma non c'avevo guarda
neanche mezzo dubbio anche lui è
contento giusto per farvi capire chi
comanda
invece da capitelli dirlo
allora io ti ho portato qui in questo
viaggio perché oggi voglio chiederti di
sposarmi si è sciolto anche il cane si è
sciolto ora di che nella parte il cazzo
siamo venuti qua perché questo posto ci
si fa la foto bella e poi la [ __ ] arriva
ogni chi l'hai visto il canale secondo
te quanti iscritti già
allora ragazzi oggi di vento katniss
everdeen
il distretto codice
[Musica]
ciao salvare fitta che ha già visto
cazzo quando sei in gita però allo
stesso tempo non ce la fai a non giocare
a deporre ok ragazzi adesso
multigiocatore
la vista
ma perche la mia
si no
dei professionisti siamo cambio di gioco
ragazzi bisogna provare a buttare le
palline dentro il buco e io di centrare
i buchi me ne intendo tanto perche
fascia
[Musica]
bene
ruota troppo pizzo zero
che siamo staccati
ma qualcuno ci è mai riuscita secondo
voi
grazie
è una dichiarazione d'amore una papera
ha capito con chi comanda allora ragazzi
le balle non sono tre ore 56 ballen sono
6 euro che vanno a compimento di caccia
e un'incredibile miriam en contra n
le cose vinciamo tutte
[Musica]
poi vinto
sei tornata sono ritornate la giornata
forza sasha ma come fai questo ha messo
tutto va bene va bene
tutte tranne una tasca e non è muto nel
mio
ho visto un cartoncino bravo saggio
della mia o cartoncino la vittoria ce
n'è un altro per me
grazie grazie grazie
dai una papera è un under punte c'è
scritto quando il punto sull'azione bene
due punti attenzione abbiamo unito i due
nostri premi per vincerne uno più grosso
che questo signore qua questo signore
quando non ho voglio signora voi blu
rosa e rosso
ping ping ping perché gli uomini
prendono quello grazie la [ __ ] a casa
adesso
quando la papera si prende troppa
confidenza e diventa addirittura nel
mito bene va bene la ragazza aveva
ordinato la pizza in camera siamo io
mister league i box la sabri che sta
continuando a giocare con la pista non
aprì bocca
mister animo anima box fabi boxing
comunque abbiamo arrivato a pizza in
camera non essendoci abbastanza spazio
sul tavolo ma stiamo mangiando nel letto
il problema è che non abbiamo le posate
quindi un problema basta che l'area la
pizza che nel mio letto porca [ __ ] ma
tagliamo come così che a [ __ ] ciò che
sta riuscendo come aspetta di esse è
fatta col cemento
beh mi fa piacere è quindi ragazzi più o
meno questa è stata la nostra avventura
ataf stavo dicendo a los angeles non so
perche tra tutte le cose che abbiamo
fatto forse la più spericolata di tutte
mangiare la pizza ma non tanto perché
abbiamo mangiato sul letto ma perché qui
facciamo veramente cagare cazzo vi dico
solo ragazzi che là dove l'abbiamo
ordinata la pizza potete ordinare anche
alla pizza con l'ananas ho detto tutto
non che regga suoli questa è stata la
mia la nostra esperienza ad amsterdam
spero vi sia piaciuta con cui episodio
ragazzi cose sulle misure sul momento è
un mi piace anche a piace di facebook e
coin di facebook un cazzo come
nitidamente iscrizione ci vediamo al
prossimo vitobello ragazzi